we're on problem 36 it says which of the
following sentences is true about the
graphs of y is equal to 3 times x minus
5 squared plus 1 and y equals 3 times x
plus 5
squared plus 1. so let's just let's do
it something very similar to what we did
in the past and if you think about it
both of these equations y is going to be
one or greater let me just you know
let's just
analyze this a little bit right
this term right here let me
this term right here
since we're squaring is always going to
be positive right even if the what's
inside the parentheses becomes negative
if we have you know x is minus 10 inside
the parentheses becomes negative but
when you square it it always becomes
positive and you're going to multiply
three times a positive number so you're
going to get a positive number so the
lowest value that this could be is zero
so the lowest value that y could be is
actually one and same thing here
the lowest value that you know this
number can become very negative but when
you square it it's going to become
positive so this expression with this
with the squared here is going to be
positive when you multiply 3 it's going
to be positive so the lowest value here
is always going to be 0 and you include
this whole term when you include this
whole term so similarly the lowest value
y could be is 1. i just want to think
about it a little bit just to give you a
little bit of an intuition and let's
let's think of this in the context of
what we talked learned last time with
the shifting
so let me draw it in a color that you
can see
so if that is the
y axis and i'll just draw mainly the
positive area
so let's see this is
so if i were to just draw y is equal to
x squared plus 1
it would look like this where this is 1
that's y is equal to 1 and the graph
would look something of along this
y is equal to x squared plus 1. oh
that's a horrible drawing and normally i
wouldn't redo it but that was just
atrocious y is equal to x squared plus 1
looks something like that it's symmetric
you know the you get the idea you've
seen these parabolas before this is y is
equal to x squared plus one
x squared plus one
now
if we were to do
x
x minus five squared plus one what
happens to it well let me think what is
3x squared plus 1 well then it just
increases a little bit faster so if i
were to say y equals 3x squared plus 1
it might look something like this
it'll just increase a little bit faster
3 times as fast actually
so that would be three x squared plus
one
right the rate of increase in both
direction just goes faster because you
have this constant term three out there
multiplying the numbers okay
now what happens when you shift it
when you shift so let's do x minus five
so
where x equals zero was the minimum
point before now when if we substitute a
five here that'll be our minimum point
right because then that whole term
becomes zero
so
this vertex will now be shifted to the
right let me do another color
so if this is the point five
now this would be the graph you just
took this graph and you shifted it over
to the right by five i won't draw the
whole thing
that graph right there
would be three times x minus five
squared plus one and remember the the y
shift is always intuitive if you add one
you're shifting it up if you subtract
one you're shifting it down the x shift
isn't we subtracted five
x minus five we replaced x with x minus
five but we shifted to the right and the
intuition is there is because now plus
five makes this expression zero
so that's three x minus five squared and
then the same logic 3 times x plus 5
squared is going to be here plus 1.
so if we shift it that's going to be
shifted to the let me pick a good color
to the left
this is going to look something like
this going to be this blue graph shifted
to the left so this is minus 5.
so this is the graph right here
of 3 times x plus 5
squared plus 1.
now hopefully you have an intuition so
let's read their statements and see
which one makes sense which of the
following is true
their vertices are maximums no that's
not true of any of these because the
vertices is the
is that point right there and they're
actually it's a minimum point
right a maximum point would look
something like that
and we know that because you just go
positive this term can only be positive
if this was a negative 3 then it would
flip it over
okay so it's not choice a
the graphs have the same shape with
different vertices yeah
both of these graphs have the shape of
3x squared but the one vertices is 10 to
the left of the other one so i think b
is our choice let's read the other ones
the graphs have different shapes with
different verses now they have the same
shape they definitely have the same
shape i mean they both have this 3x
squared
shape
one graph has a vertex that is a maximum
while the other has a graph no that's
not right they both are upward facing so
they both have minimum points so it's
choice b
choice b next problem problem 37
37
let me see what it says
what are the x intercepts let me copy
and paste that
okay and now paste it there
what are the x-intercepts of the graph
of that well the x-intercepts whatever
this graph looks like i don't know
exactly what it looks like
you know i don't know what you know this
graph is going to look something like
this
i actually have no idea what it looks
like until i solve it it's going to look
something like this when they say
x-intercepts they're like where does it
intersect the x-axis so that's like
there and there i don't know if those
are the actual points right and to do
that we set
the function equal to zero because this
is the point y is equal to zero you're
essentially saying when does this
function equal zero because that's the
x-axis when y is equal to zero so you
set y is equal to 0 and you get
0 is equal to 12 x squared
minus 5 x minus 2
and whenever i have a a coefficient
larger than 1 in front of the x squared
term i find that very hard to just
eyeball and factor so i use the
quadratic equation
so
negative b this is b
b is minus five so negative negative
five is plus five right negative b
plus or minus the square root of b
squared negative 5 squared is 25
minus 4 times
a which is 12
times c which is minus 2 times minus 2.
so let's just make that times plus 2 and
put the plus out there right minus times
minus is a plus all of that over 2a
all that over 24
2 times a
so that is equal to
let me see 5 plus or minus the square
root
see it was 25
plus
4 times 4 plus 12
4 times 12
times 2 right because that was a minus 2
but we had a minus there before so 8
times 12 so 96
96 all of that over 24
what's 25 plus 96 that's 101's 121 right
this is 121
which is 11 squared so this becomes
5 plus or minus 11
over 24.
so
remember these are the points where
these are the x values where that
original function
will equal 0. it's always important to
remember what we're even doing
so let's see so if x is equal to 5 plus
11 over 24 that is equal to 16 over 24
which is equal to two-thirds
that's one potential intercept so you
know maybe
that's right here right that's x is
equal to two thirds and y is equal to
zero and the other value is x is equal
to five minus eleven over twenty four
and that's what minus six over 24 which
is equal to minus 1 4 which could be
this point i actually drew the graph not
that far off of what it could be so this
would be x is equal to minus 1 4. and
those are the x-intercepts of that graph
so see two-thirds and minus one fourth
is choice c
choice c on the test
i think we have time for at least one
more
let's see where
oh boy they do a solid graph so which is
the graph let me shrink it
i want to be able to fit all the graphs
so let me copy and paste their graphs
so
this is one where the clipboard is
definitely going to come in useful
let me
oh it doesn't okay that's good enough
okay so they want to know which is the
graph of
so let me
i've never
done something this graphical let's see
so the graph they say is y is equal to
minus two times x minus one
squared plus one so that's what we have
to find the graph of
so immediately when you look at it so
you say okay this is like the same thing
as
y is equal to
minus two x squared plus one but they
shifted the x right they shifted the x
to the right by one i know it says a
minus one but think about it when x is
equal to positive one this is equal to
zero
and and if so it's going to be shifted
to the right by one
right
plus one we know that we know that it's
going to be shifted up by one right
so up
plus 1.
and then we have to think is it going to
be opening upwards or downwards think of
it this way if this was if this was y is
equal to 2x squared plus 1 then this
term would always be positive and it'll
just come more and more positive as you
get further and further away from zero
so it would open up but if you put a
negative number there if you say y is
equal to minus two x squared plus one
then you're going to open downward
you're just going to get more and more
negative as you get away from your
vertex right
so we're shifted to the right by one
we're shifted up by one and we're going
to be opening downwards so if we look at
our choices only these two are shifting
are opening downwards
and both of them are shifted up by one
their y
the vertex is at
y is equal to one but this is shifted
one to the right and this is shifted one
to the left
and remember we said it was x minus one
squared so the vertex happens when this
whole expression is equal to zero and
this whole expression is equal to zero
when
x minus one when x is equal to positive
one when x is equal to positive one
so that's right here
so it's actually choice
c
and that's probably that's when you're
shifting graphs that can be one of the
kind of hardest things to ingrain but i
just really encourage you to
explore graphs practice graph practice
with graphs with your graphing
calculator and really try to plot points
and try to get a really good grasp of
why when you go from minus two x squared
plus one to minus two times x minus one
squared well when you replace an x with
an x minus one why this shifts the graph
to the right by one
anyway i'll see you in the next video